today's topic how do you get out of the
friend zone
first what is the friend zone the friend
zone doesn't exist
he was about to say that uh i believe
that friends don't exist but in a
certain
particular way okay what is the friend
zone
if you ask a girl and you want the girl
to sleep with you or you want a
relationship with a girl
and she says no that's not the friend
zone
you took a l and that's fine take your
hell humbly
and leave the girl don't owe you to
sleep or to be whatever whatever
what a friend zone is it if you ask the
girl
xyz whether it's to go out with her or
uh to have relationship
or to sleep with her or anything like
that and she says no
but she uses that as leverage to make
you do
things then that she puts you
a friend in the friend zone because she
she takes advantage of that
right now it's also your choice to leave
her to stay stop being so agreeable with
everybody just because you wanna
that's being dishonest and that's the
thing sometimes it's it's
you that put yourself in the friend zone
it's you that put yourself there it's
you that
how do you get out of the friend zone
stop being so agreeable most of the time
is because
you are agreeable because you want that
cookie that's
you have to put yourself in the in the
position of a woman how unappealing it
is
they see what you're doing women they
see and they know what you're doing they
look at you
like oh you're being all nice and this
and that because you want some of that
it's not necessarily how you are maybe
it is how you are but sometimes you can
say no just start saying no not because
you just want to say but sometimes when
you don't feel like it you don't feel
like it no i just don't want to do that
no that's not i wouldn't do it like that
no let's do that instead
start to assess yourself a little bit
more and if you still
don't get what you want then it's
because she doesn't want what you want
take your l and leave go see other
things in other places
and move over that person that person
has the right to say no
okay don't lurk around and stay around
in hopes of
i hope i'm gonna be the one and i hope
one day she's gonna say yes and
next time i'm gonna be next in line
who's that guy
you're not next you can't be your friend
i'm the friend because friend means next
you know what i mean you can't do that
stop doing that
if you feel your friend zone and
whatever it means
get out because you wanted a
relationship you don't have that
relationship it has the only thing that
you want
move scooch you have other options
that's pretty much it that's how you get
out of friend zone
so yes and no the friend zone doesn't
doesn't exist i get that
because you can always exit it by
yourself
but what you mean when you say oh how do
i exit the friend zone is
how do i go from friend to you know
boyfriend and that's not necessarily
exiting the friend zone
that's having a promotion but anyways
that's besides the point
leave leave you don't have to stay there
you don't have to stay in that position
that's putting too much that's putting
your fate in the hands of a
of that girl or that guy or whatever
it's putting your faith
they i don't have any control you choose
my fate they're king
sam past motherfu get out do you or do
you know
no i move on
that's it what i don't know
there's something always about this
question that's always bothering me what
is it let's explore it then
what is it about this question that's
bothering you
it's simpy it's pitiful
how do i get out of it it's just like if
you have
if you have any self-respect and dignity
you're not going to be there so
to me it's not a matter of strategy it's
a matter of just building your
self-esteem
you have a healthy sense of self-esteem
you're just not going to put yourself in
a situation where you're dishonest with
the people
you claim you want to date sorry that
woman has a right to say no it's just
very
it feels inside i'm in the friend zone
it's very like you know
whether it's a girl whether it's a dude
doing it a friend zoning people like it
doesn't matter it's just like
just have some dignity have some dignity
don't allow yourself to be treated in a
way that you feel is being taken
advantage of you just because you have
some
desires for that person that's pathetic
so so it's just like
get out do i have to tell you to have
some dignity do i have to come here and
be like
bro have some dignity uh bro
try to love yourself like do i have to
come here and tell you that like what am
i
why am i here why are you here oh yes
why do you need this info people don't
know i need to remind you don't worry
yes
yeah yeah you're worthy of love and
dignity why did you say that
you didn't didn't you feel good saying
that i get to say that
that face no i was just like
i have to come boo boo perspective like
i have to say that
yeah you do you do you have to remind
people sometimes
yeah you do you do have to remind people
sometimes yeah
i don't know maybe figure i don't know
i'll just preach is much more empathetic
than i am
deal with it preachers much more what
empathetic
okay that's not what i heard priest is
much more pathetic than i am
[ __ ] what well yeah you are simply
[ __ ] i'm not saying yeah you friend
zoned
to who by my people
you literally people
yeah yeah that's what i thought
nothing yeah that's what i thought
anyways that's it for today's video oh
yeah you said yeah people
[Music]
me